hey this is press to
Walker here are two fun logic puzzles
from puzzling stack
exchange problem
one Alice Bob and Charlie are one of
each type a truth teller that always
tells the truth a liar that always lies
and a spy can lie or tell the
truth Alice says she is not a truth tell
Bob says he is not a spy and Charlie
says he is not a liar what type is
Charlie a truth teller B liar C spy D
there's not enough
information problem
two here's a delightful puzzle Charlie
has
$1,000 he can buy his favorite chocolate
bar for
$1 and there is a promotion
for every four chocolate wrappers
submitted the store will give one
chocolate bar what is the maximum number
of chocolate bars Charlie can
get pause the video if you'd like to
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve these
[Music]
problems
let's solve problem one here's one way
to visualize a
solution let's make a 3X3 grid where the
rows are Alice Bob and Charlie and the
columns are truth tell liar and spy
Alice Bob and Charlie are one of each
type so suppose that Alice is a truth
teller then Alice cannot be any of the
other types and no one else can be a
truth tell so we can eliminate the row
and
column so Bob could be a liar and that
would would eliminate the rest of the
row and the rest of the column that
means Charlie has to be the
Spy so we see that the possibilities are
determined once we figured out what two
people are now if instead Bob was a spy
then Charlie would have to be a liar so
if Alice is a true teller there are only
two possibilities to consider now
suppose instead that Alice was a liar
then we would need either Bob to be a
spy and Charlie to be a truth teller or
vice versa
finally if Alice were a spy then there
are only two possibilities to consider
Bob could be a truth teller and Charlie
could be a liar or vice versa so in
total there are six possibilities to
consider so let's figure this
out so from the given information let's
imagine what if Alice were a truth
teller in that case she cannot say she
is not a truth teller that would be a
contradiction so it's not possible for
for Alice to be a truth teller If
instead Alice were a liar then she would
always lie but saying she's not a truth
teller would then be a true statement so
that means Alice has to be a spy so we
figured out that this has to be Alice a
spy so we can eliminate the row and the
column so Bob and Charlie only have two
possibilities so let's narrow it
down if Bob were a liar then he would
all always lie but saying he is not a
spy would then be a truth
statement but we know that Bob cannot be
a spy that's already taken so it must be
that Bob is a truth teller so we can
then eliminate the row and the column
and that means Charlie has to be a liar
so we figured it out by process of
elimination the correct answer is B
Charlie is a
liar
now let's solve problem
two so the first way is the long way
we'll consider the step the number of
bars that Charlie can get and the number
of wrappers divided by four so in the
very first step Charlie can take the
$1,000 and get 1,000 chocolate
bars then we can take that to be 1,000
wrappers ided 4 which gives
250 additional chocolate bars so in step
two Charlie can get 250 chocolate bars
we then take those 250 wrappers and
divide it by four and we get
62.5 so you want to be careful about
accounting here so Charlie can use
248 of those which is an evenly
divisible by four number he'll be left
with two of the wrappers so in the next
step we take 248 / by 4 and we get 62
more chocolate bars then Charlie can
take those 62 wrappers with the two
wrappers that are left over making for a
total of 64 wrappers so this will be 64
/ 4 which is 16 more chocolate bars that
Charlie could get so then in the next
step we have 16 more bars 16 is
divisible by four that gives four more
for the next step so then we have four
more bars four ided four is one so in
the final step he gets one more bar and
that's it he can't get any more so the
total number of chocolate bars is the
sum of numbers in this column and this
works out to be
1,333 chocolate bars and that is the
answer now this is the long way to solve
the problem here's a clever trick
imagine Charlie buys one chocolate bar
per day so on the very first day or day
Zero he buys one chocolate and has
$999
left now think about buying one
chocolate bar on the next three days so
he'll get three chocolates and you'll
have three fewer dollars so that'll be
$996 left now at this point we can add
up that there are four chocolate
wrappers so on day four he can use those
four wrappers to get one free chocolate
bar then we just repeat
this on days 5 through 7 he buys three
more chocolates and has
$993 left on day eight he can use the
wrappers from day four which was the
free bar plus the three he bought to get
one free chocolate bar and this pattern
will continue the next three days he'll
buy three more chocolates subtracting $3
more doll then use the four wrappers to
get one free chocolate so we can
summarize the pattern
after he buys one chocolate on Day Zero
for every $3 spent Charlie can get four
chocolate
bars so how many chocolate bars can he
get additionally this will be 999 / 3
multiplied by 4 which equals
1,332 more chocolate bars so in total
this will be 1 +
1332 which equals 1,3 33 chocolate bars
and that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time